why why do you say that debating about
Free Will is unproductive what I what I
notice is that people will have the same
conversations over and over again and if
I tune in on one or I tune in on another
I've pretty much heard all of the
arguments that are being
Advanced okay so it's not the problem
itself it's the framework of the problem
it's the problem relative to the
framework that we're in where people
will have a conversation that'll go on
for an hour before anyone will ask the
question do we even know what we mean by
free will I'm willing to commit to you
on this podcast that 20 years from now
we're still going to be having free will
discussions if we don't have a more
profound Theory of physics